les vidéos captées pendant les braquages
et mise en ligne sur les réseaux sociaux
sont la vru de deux jeunes gens ariel
sommers et d'une telle offre
le couple est maintenant suivie par des
millions d'abonnés sur les réseaux
sociaux est considéré par d'autres
personnes
salut je m'appelle ariel
ho depuis aussi loin que je me souvienne
j'ai toujours su qu'un jour je
deviendrai célèbre
[Musique]
l'aïe
je me disais que je n'avais encore
jamais vu par ici
oui toi
tu sais
c'est une toute petite ville
peu que je me casse de floride
d'abord je trouve quelqu'un qui veut
venir avec moi
oui
jamais
faire contre vite du cachet à
[Applaudissements]
j'espère que tu aimes le vert tu as de
la chance
un médecin turc
[Musique]
j'étais un compte hier soir on a 3 me
fall hour pourquoi t'as fait ça un truc
comme ça c'est pas courant nous rendre
super célèbre maintenant on va s'amuser
pour vous ça bouge bien à ce que je vois
c'est et huawei le couple est suivi par
des millions d'abonnés est considéré
comme une version moderne de bonnie and
clyde
[Musique]
samoa et samoa là dedans comment tu
crois que ça va finir non ça je fais pas
une fille d'intérieur
sera pas l'air de te rendre compte de ce
que ça peut faire pour nous qui comprend
plus rien du tout à des trucs de réseau
[Musique]
avec les bébés
car
comme classique a pas mieux qu'un bon
vieux braquage de banque